today we're talking about apogee x
baseball and bigquery ai workshops for
free and mo inspired candy
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
to help customers globally scale api
programs
we're pleased to bring the power of
google's networking capabilities to api
management
apigee x the latest release of google
cloud's full lifecycle api management
platform
it makes it easy and simple to apply
cloud
content delivery network cdn to apis
working in tandem the two solutions let
enterprises not only secure and manage
their apis
but also make them available across a
global ecosystem of stakeholders
with the start of baseball upon us learn
how bigquery helps
scale and automate insights for baseball
fans
and businesses alike and while baseball
serves as a fun playground
parts of the process outlined here can
be used across
all industries that have big data and
want to turn it into timely contextual
succinct bits of valuable information
with
vastly improved efficiency relying on
automation
google cloud is offering no cost
training opportunities to help
you gain the latest ai and machine
learning skills
you'll have a chance to learn more about
the new document
ai along with explainable ai looker
bigquery ml and dialog flow cx
check out the blog post to register
it's tough to resist candy and even
tougher to resist the magic of a mel
so it's obvious why we jumped at the
opportunity to collaborate with mars inc
on an ai driven recipe with maltesers
our own sarah robinson explore the
relationship between
ai and baking in order to whip up
something really really special
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you